hallo herzlich willkommen zur sally
fällt mit murat genau ich will auch
dabei und zwar machen wir den garten
winterfest
kein garten winterfest wir machen den
garten winterfest ja und im sommer
sommerfest ein saurer fans genau weil
ihr habt danach gefragt haben wir schon
gesehen haben schon vorgaben gemacht ein
video gemacht über den rollrasen würde
investors anlagen über die hochbeete die
hochbeete über das gartenhäuschen hörig
gemacht haben wir nicht vergessen dass
heißt es gab ein häuschen gibt es sorgt
und wir machen gute pace ist kommt die
kalte jahreszeit und sollte man am
besten im herzen noch machen also
nachdem hertz nachdem er die letzten
sachen abgeerntet habt und wirklich noch
die volle kraft des gartens aus genutzt
habt könnt ihr den garten winterfest
genau interface karten heiß den rasen
die hochbeete die investors anlage die
obstbäume bewässerungsanlage restaurant
waren es noch 1 jahr nach obstbäume den
olivenbaum winterfest machen genau und
im prinzip alles was eben noch so punkt
den garten also um das haus im garten
herum anstrengen genau ich kümmere mich
um den rasen
ich mag die pflanzen ich mache
olivenbaum ich mache die hochbeete und
das war ja auch noch und dann kommt
schon der christian da hilft uns halten
habe ich dabei wirklich da hilft dann
fangen nicht an und du kannst so lange
kaffee
genau wie es gleich den garten
winterfest machen bedeutet natürlich
auch direkt zu ein pflanzen was eben
jetzt zum wachsen soll
wenn wir jetzt auch diesen elvira bach
gepflanzt und damals auch schon gesagt
das ist auch die perfekte jahreszeit
denn der boden ist feucht vom herbst
aber noch warm genug vom sommer können
auf ist einfach so dass bis vier grad
bodentemperatur noch wurzelbildung
stattfindet und das heißt der hat jetzt
dann einfach in den wachstumsvorsprung
gegenüber dem zeitpunkt wenn wir
märz/april pflanzt das heißt der wurzel
der c anordnung stelle fest und kann im
frühjahr direkt hier loslegen das ist
ein riesenvorteil ich gerade den
widerrufs verlauten wie wir sie in den
letzten jahren habe geht es jetzt mit
allem oder jetzt nur mit obstbäumen mit
nahezu allem wo ich ein bisschen
vorsichtig wäre einfach die
frostempfindlichen pflanzen wie oliven
zu pressen und so weiter weil dann ist
es einfach draußen schon ein bisschen zu
kalt ja aber alles andere da ist es
wirklich so dass der herbst die beste
pflanzzeit ist okay also der herbst ist
die beste pflanzzeit außer bei
kälteempfindlichen pflanzen können
perfekt super also es war immer ein
wunsch genau dass es ganz früh schon im
garten blüht und ja das bühnenleben die
die zwiebelpflanzen erkennt und für die
zwiebelpflanzen gibt es nur einen
richtigen zeitpunkt die in die erde zu
fliegen dass das jetzt im herbst dafür
gibt es dieses wunderbare hilfsmitteln
und dazu haben jetzt gleich mal wie das
geht ok damit bohren wir bestimmt können
auch damit machen wir das loch gezogen
einfach zu pflanzen
so haben wir jetzt die die cocos zwiebel
es ist häufig die frage wie tief konsole
zwiebeln in die erde
die cocos zwiebel ist jetzt ein finger
hoch das heißt sie wird doppelt so hoch
mit erde bedeckt das heißt dem fall
das lockt einfach 340 als ich hier soll
es wieder schön blöd ja genau
also hier soll es ganz früh losgehen mit
der blüte und dafür können wir eben
dieses wunderbare hilfsmittel nehmen
haben wir schon erklärte das loch für
die kokons muss sie nicht wahr drei
finger breit tief sein
ok also dreimal so tief wie die zwiebel
jeweils groß ist das heißt ich kann das
hier einmal abmessen also so tief sollte
die zwiebel liegen dh du merkst dir
einfach so diesen stelle und soweit
macht man da jetzt einfach noch so dann
wie zwiebel rein genau die nase immer
die nase immer nach oben zunächst jetzt
haben wir die wende noch ein bisschen
größer machen wollte sie einfach rein
und nase heißt für dich praktisch steht
die genaue die haben jetzt sogar schon
ein bisschen angetrieben das sind die
betriebe nach oben und die die eben hier
rein und dann kann man einfach noch mal
so ein bisschen daneben stechen dann ist
das loch zu und bei den kokons so wie es
auch hier auf dem bild ist und es ist
immer schön in die kleine gruppen bilden
das heißt man kann da ein paar fahren
ich ja neben fachlicher nebeneinander
machen mit dem nächsten lochbrücke das
vorhergehende einfach zu perfekt jetzt
haben wir's an gedrückt und zum
abschluss träume einfach nur ein
bisschen von dem ehemaligen drüber ich
erinnere mich genau pinguin code genau
damit alles gut versorgt ist okay
diesmal am nächsten nicht ein
ich hatte letztens schon gedruckt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt einen kleinen olivenbaum
genau da muss auch geschützt werden muss
geschützt werden
hier machen wir nicht den aufwand mit
dieser begleit heizung weil das steht
hier wunderschön jahr an der ecke und
schon relativ geschützt als hilfsmittel
habe ich wie so ein kleines mit baum aus
dem heim bambusstäben gebaut die die
werden so leicht in die erde
reingesteckt ist dem titel vom fenster
eines tv genau und das schöne ist wenn
wir jetzt gleich das vlies hier dran
machen wirklich dann schnee fallen
sollte der rutscht immer runter und ok
und es ist lastet eben keine schneelast
auf der olive und wenn man das vlies nur
hier drüber machen würden und es würde
sie mehr schnee fallen dann dann wäre es
einfach zu viel gewicht und das
vermeidet man wenn man so weit weg meint
hier würde theoretisch auch der eine
fall ausreichen nachdem ihr zeige ich
jetzt einfach mal wieder sieht man das
kann man dann auch auf andere pflanzen
übertragen ja und wir benutzen hits und
vlies und keine folie denn bei einer
folie ist so wie bei einem gewächshaus
da kommt praktisch keine luft durch es
gibt keine luft raus und wenn die sonne
hier bei uns im süden drauf scheint wird
natürlich viel zu warm das heißt wer
auch anfällig für pilz oder schimmel zum
beispiel und durch das vlies geht die
luft durch es entsteht eine
luftzirkulation und vor allem holt sich
das bei mir auch die feuchtigkeit hier
über den boden und ja deswegen fließen
keine rolle
[Musik]
also einmal zum wickeln damit waren bin
ich weg weit unten fest binden
wenn man schöne lichterkette daran macht
hat man direkt schon den tannenbaum geld
gespart wird der morales sagen
der bau hat jetzt kuschelig warm über
den winter hinweg hier so weit schon mal
direkt richtig denn bei den kräutern und
blumen zeige ich euch gleich um
christian zusammen was man jetzt reitet
und ob überhaupt zurückgeschnitten wird
der rote sonnenhut der ja immer noch
richtig schön genau der politik seit
monaten und wir haben jetzt november und
ja was sich beim richtigen punkt nämlich
beim schneiden wo ganz viele leute
fahren was wir denn im herbst
geschnitten ja richtig schneidet mainz
nicht zurück oder sie lassen wir jetzt
ich würde die auch immer stehen lassen
für viele leute ist es immer so das
bedürfnis mit dem garten ordentlich und
sauber haben im herbst also da beim
schnee dem herz geht es vielmehr um die
optik ok hatte man gar nichts muss man
gar nicht schneiden auch wenn der rote
sonnenhut dann tatsächlich verfügt hat
finde ich es schön wenn er einfach als
struktur stehen bleibt genauso wie oder
so der fenchel den in denen wir hier zum
beispiel auch haben also ich muss echt
sagen ich bin ein fan von im frühjahr
zurück schneiden weil ich denke im
winter muss einfach alles winterfest
sein alles was kaputtgehen camus rhein
und im frühjahr ist für mich immer so
frühjahrsputz und garten nach schneide
ich dann gerne zurück außerdem ist es
wärmer draußen aber wenn man es doch
zurückschneiden will hier zusammenfassen
und mit so noch kein cappuccino oder du
hast mir sogar noch was mitgebracht oder
mit sonne
kleinen schönen heckenschere noch mehr
spaß
genau wie vor allem man muss sich nicht
also kann man
wenn ich draußen stehen heraus viele
schneiden hier auch im winter gerne die
hecken zurück und dann hat man hier eben
direkt die schnittfläche und da kann
wirklich auch frust eintreten also am
besten die hacken auch erst im frühjahr
zurückschneiden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das wächst haben wir dann nächstes jahr
schön raus genau das treibt durch wäre
da ist es wohl wenn man das zu spät
abschneidet läuft man gefahr dass man
einfach vom neuen heim die spitzen
erwischt deswegen hat in kübeln wenn man
se ein wunderbarer zeitpunkt ist es mir
beim trompetenbaum was machen
also werden sie jetzt schon ein paar mal
über über den schnitt des jahres im
herbst gar nicht so wirklich viel machen
muss nur das was ein wirklich stört und
ich habe vor allem gesehen schauen dies
sind 23 triebe gebrochen
die kann man natürlich jetzt wunderbar
entfernen weil im lautlosen zustanden
sieht man so was natürlich viel besser
wie wenn der komplett behauptet hatte
und jetzt versucht man mit der schere
der hoch zu kommen
das hat seine morath fragen ich brauche
jetzt gerade kurz
kannst du mal da oben den gebrochenen
acht abschneiden kann man nicht
runterreißen der juden der joschi haben
es wieder im raum gedüngt
man sagt ja dass sich alle juden und
zwar der klubs jahrmarkt in passau auf
dem auf mussawis voraus hat ist der büro
und also hier oben gerade das was kaputt
ist das schneiden wir dann komplett raus
ja noch weiter unten anderen leid da
unten hier genau
das ist wirklich sonnenteleskop super
hilfsmittel die allem einfach für die
reichweite guten meter verlängern heißt
hier kommen die leute auch noch hin
[Musik]
murat perfekt hast du heute gebacken
danke risiko hammer selbst gemacht
wahnsinn ich denke weil ich dich will
ich euch liebe business ihr tipp ich ihn
offen
da ich muss auf yoshi aufpassen
sie zählen von waagen gartenhaus es hat
ja schön große fenster umgestellt alle
pflanzen rein die immer grün sind und
die die wir eben den köpfen haben genau
und wie frostempfindlich sehen hier ein
bisschen mehr geschützt werden müssen
als mit dem face ja für eignet sich
somit ganzen haus ideal wir haben jetzt
hier den eukalyptus und den pac man
direkt in die scheibe ja
[Musik]
ich wollte dir gerade abnehmer und ich
glaube du bist stärker als ich der
christian dell bringt wir uns noch alle
pflanzen rein und ich werde jetzt schon
mal ein bisschen gießen über den winter
hinweg macht man das so vier bis fünf
mal dass der boden leicht feucht ist
denn die pflanzen die sind ja immer grün
und brauchen einfach noch ein bisschen
wasser bei pflanzen überwintern sollen
die keine blätter dran haben da muss man
nicht geben denn da findet keine
verdunstung statt wenn die verdunstung
findet immer über das grüne blatt statt
also brauche ich hier bei der hortensien
nichts machen
die können theoretisch auch dunkel
stehen aber hier bei den grünen pflanzen
da stecke ich jetzt die flasche rein und
dann nimmt sich die pflanzen so viel
wasser wie sie benötigt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und am schönen wetter tagen könnt ihr
gerne auch mal die tür offen stehen
lassen damit luft sehr kollegen kann
frischer sauerstoff rein kommt und dann
schließt sie einfach die tür wieder
selbst gefällt wird
[Musik]
das war hier noch die hochbeete
winterfest und hier ist jetzt am
hochbeet wo im prinzip das ganze gemüse
eingeplant war mein papa da kam uns
schon zuvor die tomatenpflanzen schon
raus genommen
das heißt hier nehme ich nur noch meine
schilder weg aber ihr müsst ihr
tomatenpflanzen nicht einmal
wegschmeißen sondern legt sie wirklich
einfach direkt drauf dass verrottet und
alles über den winter und die natur
macht es uns eigentlich schon vor
denn der wald zum beispiel denkt sich
auch von ganz alleine im herbst lässt
die blätter fallen alles legt sich auf
den boden und dann können sich die
pflanzen die nährstoffe direkt schon im
frühjahr holen gerade wenn so die ersten
warmen temperaturen kommen und jetzt
werden wir auch schon den boden düngen
werden hier auch ein bisschen erde dann
auffüllen ihr seht auch wirklich runter
gesagt und dann haben wir die hochbeete
bereit fürs nächste ein paar kräuter die
lassen drinnen gerne mal die sind ja
mehrere winterfest und mehrjährig genau
aber hat die tomaten und paprika mangold
es niemals alles raus genau das was ihr
eben schon erwähnt wir haben ja damals
schon gesagt alles was wir jährlich
neuen pflanzen da gehen wir davon aus
dass es wunder sagt ja dann haben wir
einfach im nächsten jahr und die
möglichkeit da frische unverbrauchte
erde aufzufüllen um das bereitet mir
jetzt im prinzip vor und wir ziehen erst
in dem moment wo wir die frische erde
auf die bewässerung nach oben das nicht
obenauf liegt wo ich sie immer
kontrolliert niemand kontrollieren kann
alles klar
das heißt jetzt tun wir nur und nächstes
jahr filme dann auf
[Musik]
hier sind jetzt noch samen drin und
genau die würden wir jetzt hier nicht
mit rein setzen denn es wächst ja alles
nächstes jahr wieder
das heißt wenn ihr die samen euch nehmen
wollt dann nehmen sie raus laste
trocknen setzt sie nächstes jahr ein
aber das kommt jetzt hier bei uns nicht
ins hochbeet damit eben nicht alles
einfach wild wächst
ich weiß noch bei uns vom haus da waren
ganz viele wilde tomaten und diesen auch
wiedergekommen zwischen den blumen haben
wir nicht kontrollieren können
und hier und jetzt noch die guten
blätter abnehmen damit rein die werde
ich einfrieren und alles was jetzt hier
nicht mehr so gut ist das nehmen wir
direkt versteht sich
du hast ja gesagt nicht wirklich da eine
temperatur machst du so lebst ja alles
auf einen kaufen matthias ganz bequem
durch sortieren und das erhalten was du
warst du noch mädels was du noch
verwerten kann ja
[Musik]
die guten die nehmen wir jetzt gleich
mit rein
die werden dann gewaschen werden
geschnitten und eingefroren so habe ich
immer man gut auf vorrat
[Musik]
kurator ist verstehe ich im supermarkt
findest du das so ja gar nicht der krieg
schon immer nur sellerie stangen und
sellerieknolle wenn beides nehmen wir
jetzt mit rein und die friere ich dann
auch immer gerne ein und dann nehme ich
die genfer war es gibt sellerie ja
[Musik]
baby karotten auf dem bug auf so was
viele ja definitiv
[Musik]
guckt euch das mal an dieser mangold wie
schön der aussieht als hätte man ein
gefährt aber das ist ganz natürlich ohne
allein wegen der tollen farben
eingepflanzt und bin ich doch gern esse
[Musik]
und die pflanzen die schützen hier jetzt
erst mal die erde und sie schützt die
erde vor allem auch für unkraut die
gurken und sich fest
wir sind hier rein gewachsen oh mein
gott ich die starke gegen mensch so
jetzt immerhin mal ganz ganz besonderem
es ist sozusagen jeder der bei uns im
garten kommt sieht diesen baum ist ein
olivenbaum hat natürlich auch mit meinen
türkischen migrationshintergrund zu tun
olivenbaum in der türkei wächst
natürlich ohne ende
in deutschland hat man so seine probleme
und ich weiß dass viele leute als wir
damals und christian zusammen den baum
eingepflanzt haben gefragt haben wie es
im winter ist wir sind hier in der
badischen region und das heißt bei uns
habe ich die letzten drei jahre keinen
winter mehr gesehen trotzdem hatte
christian seine bedenken zu recht mit
euch jetzt gleich sagen warum dieser
baum ist ungefähr 200 jahre alt werden
so sein 200 so ganz genau wissen was
nicht ich war nicht dabei
aber sowieso sein dieser baum hat die
französische revolution überlebt den
ersten weltkrieg den zweiten weltkrieg
und normalerweise habe ich gedacht ich
mich oder auch noch überleben aber dafür
muss ich was machen
unter christian gesagt christus machen
wir ja wieder auf seine bedenken gute
der steht jetzt noch kein ganzes jahr
und wirklich ein jahr sollte man die
mindestens geben damit er sich richtig
akklimatisiert hat es wäre wirklich
schade wenn wenn dem überwinder was
passieren würde
deswegen helfen ihm den ersten winter
hier gut zu überstehen
in den schnee den du erwähnt hast der
erhöhte ja auch ein stück weit schützen
waren der frost nicht so ein bieten kann
gleichzeitig weil du die türkei erwähnt
hast dort haben wir einfach ein
maritimes klima wir haben eine hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit durch das meer und hier
in deutschland haben ein kontinentales
klima da haben wir einfach nicht genug
feuchtigkeit was das so einen
immergrünen
offenbar schwer macht das ist im grund
warum warum er ihm helfen sollen was wir
aber wissen müssen auch ganz wichtig ist
folgendes bei olivenbäume ist so umso
älter der olivenbaum ist und so
witterungsbeständig umso umso robuster
ist er
und da ist man ich weiß wurde letzter
sagt zu mir gesagt hast wie ein baby
wenn wir noch klein ist ein pakt ist
richtig schön ein das heißt junge bäume
junge olivenbäume darin von bäumen so
zwischen 5 bis 70 jahre alt oder ja oder
zumindest erst 21 jahre dann wenn auch
in kleinen pflanzen
schön schön einwickeln und es geht
eigentlich recht schnell also wenn ihr
euch mal so ein besonders spaß gönnt
euch ein olivenbaum im garten habe ich
weiß viele von euch haben dass es geht
ratzfatz ich muss sagen in einer halben
stunde haben es geschafft wir haben
schon ein bisschen was vorbereitet was
mir schon gemacht haben vielleicht
erklärt sich nochmal christian was wir
gemacht haben genau
also wir haben jetzt zum einmal eine
schöne heizspirale um den stamm
gewickelt
die schaltet sich nur ein wenn die
temperaturen unter null fallen und haben
hier schon mal so ein gerüst aus bambus
gebaut ähnlich wie wir es bei der
kleinen olivia gemacht haben dass wenn
schnee fallen sollte dass der mit dem
vlies nicht auf den trieben lasten
irgend etwas abbricht genau
also wie gesagt die ich heiße spirale
ist nur an wenn es unter null grad fällt
wir müssen mal gucken wie viel tage ist
im jahr eigentlich unter null grad fällt
das ist doch 20 sein oder warum genau
vor allem sind es in der regel nur die
nächte und so wie heute für uns ist
relativ frisch sein wir immer noch kein
problem für den uni war alles so ist wie
gesagt kein stromfresser kein großer
stromfresser natürlich jetzt 40 bei mir
drin das was anderes aber jetzt da eine
kleine baum hier der 20 jahre 300 jahre
alte baum müssen was wir schützen und
das machen und deswegen wie gesagt diese
bambusrohre oben und jetzt noch dieses
fliegen wo die materialien dafür findet
ihr natürlich in jedem garten shop oder
in der gärtnerei geht vorbei die helfen
euch auch und die bin das jetzt nicht
verstanden habe die gärtnerei werden es
ist auch richtig gut erklären können
das ganze fest binden die ganze
heizspirale ist jetzt auch nicht großen
riesen kostenpunkt ja ok und jetzt
machen wir das vlies drauf und römer für
uns fest genau so jetzt haben wir hier
schon fließt zusammengeschnitten chris
hessen kein anderes fliesst jetzt das
ist im gut lichtdurchlässiges fließt
deswegen hellner nicht dunkel polizisten
der nicht zu stark aufheizt musik das
ist durchlässig und das ist 120 gramm
schweres schließt also mittleres
gemischt nicht so ganz dünn aber das
schützt entsprechen aber ich muss das
jetzt nicht bei dir und gärtnerei jetzt
immer eine rolle kaufen werde ich kann
das nicht so geschnitten und dann gibt
es auch fertig genähte habe ich war mir
nicht sicher ob die für die olive
reichen deswegen macht man es jetzt hier
mit stücke ok soll jetzt mal ein paar
tricks 17,2 stangen genau
[Musik]
so jetzt ihr seht ich mir jetzt drin in
diesem chor sozusagen
und deswegen ist auch wie weiße
christian gerade gesagt hat und helles
fließt probst habe ich kann höchst
gehabt ein helles fliesst damit die
sollen noch reinkommt es braucht die
pflanze natürlich oder oliven bleiben
natürlich trotzdem noch aber trotzdem
wind und wetter geschützt und hier wird
es jetzt natürlich die spirale wenn es
in die minusgrade und ein bisschen
wärmer und genau so wird es gemacht und
[Musik]
es ist ein ganz normales gummiband
elastisch
[Musik]
der baum ist jetzt winterfest ich bin es
auch winterfest wir schon kalt geworden
und ihr habt gesehen ist es ganz ganz
einfach geht ratzfatz ist auch nicht
teuer
rechne man zwischen je nach größe vom
baum zwischen 20 und 100 euro kommt
darauf an was dem großen baum das ist
und ob männer oder ohne heizung genau
mit oder ohne heizung genau also die
heizung müsse so ungefähr mit 40 50 euro
rechnen
oder ihr habt ja genau und auf jeden
fall jetzt ist der baum 100 prozent
winterfest und im frühjahr wenn es
wieder wärmer wird mach das weg und das
ist einfach genial aus jetzt kommt
eigentlich das letzte und des letztes
ganz einfach der rasen weil der rasen
braucht auch pflege jeder rasen muss im
jahr ungefähr dreimal gedüngt werden
einmal im frühjahr einmal im sommer und
einmal im winter und wenn ihr euren
rasen nicht düngt dh dünn heißt ja
einfach nährstoffe und wenn er den rasen
nicht denkt kann folgendes passieren ihr
kriegt unkraut weil unkraut wächst nur
da an in nährstoffarmen regionen dh wenn
wenn wenn dir der rasen keine nährstoffe
hat kopp unkraut raus das andere kann
sein dass hier das müssen wir zeigen
dass die krankheit kommt er jetzt ein
ganz kurzes passen wir nicht nur wenn
der rasen ja sagt hey kumpel ich habe
einfach zu wenig nährstoffe und das
hatte ich über überall auf dem ganzen
rasen und roche spitzigkeit das ist ein
pilz und der meldet sich einfach das ist
so ein notsignal und sagt hey kumpel ich
brauche ein bisschen nährstoffe und
diese nährstoffe müsst ihr dem rasen
geben
und das schlimmste was dem rasen
passiert kann der ist dann tot ist wo es
das heißt wenn ihr einen rasen hat der
muss hat dann ist ja schon tot
und warum ist die rot spitzigkeit
quartieren den baum
dieser baum entzieht alle nährstoffe er
gibt dem rasen nimmt die ganzen
nährstoffe weg weil er schon zum wachsen
braucht und diese rot spitzigkeit findet
ja oftmals um bäume und büsche herum
wenn diese bäume die burschen ganz
nährstoffe aus dem boden raus ziehen was
sie jetzt machen muss ich habe zwei
möglichkeiten sorgen eine möglichkeit
ist mineraldünger das ist nicht neu das
ist ein mineraldünger ist muss nicht
sein
und dann gibt es noch die zweite
ökologischen die neuen richtigen
biodünger dem benutze ich da kommt
übrigens aus dem schwaben endlich aus
dem schönen ulm und es zeigt euch das
ein ganz cooles ding das ist eigentlich
wiese
den gewinn hatte ist komplett natürlich
und das ist ein den kannst du über deine
blumen machen über deine über deine
früchte über dein obst überall wo was
wächst kann es darüber machen und das
tolle ist an dem an dem bio dünger wenn
ihr selber mal jüngere benutzt habt dann
ist das problem bei mineraldünger ist es
wenn er selber mal ein dünner benutzt
hat beim mineralien ist es so wenn ihr
an einer stelle zu finden nur drauf
macht dann verbrennt alles das kann dir
alles bei den ganz normalen natur dem
nicht passieren da kannst du überall so
viel drauf machen wie du willst da
passiert nicht verboten bekommt seine
nährstoffe bei der mineraldünger ist es
wieder so wenn regen kommt und den
mineraldünger der der erheblich fest am
boden herunter gespühlt geht ins
grundwasser und damen riesenproblem wenn
wir zu viel mineraldünger im grundwasser
haben
das kann die beim natürlich nicht
passieren er hat sich richtig fest und
gibt den pflanzen und dem rasen seine
nährstoffe
das ist jetzt dieses schmuckstück aus
aufs korn
und jetzt mache ich was wir vielleicht
nicht gedacht hätte fast madrid auf
jetzt mache ich das nämlich auf und
passt mal auf das würde beim normalen
dinge niemals machen das ist ein absolut
turiner den kann ich komplett ohne
handschuhe anfassen da brauche ich gar
keine sachen da brauche ich gar keine
angst haben und jetzt ist das coole wenn
du diesen okay der richter
bis sie nach pinguin tage ein bisschen
wenn euch fragt wie fink angerichtet
anders und diesen über hier bin ich denn
jetzt auf dem boden drauf bauen um
beispiel dann zieht sich die ganzen der
grasen die ganzen pflanzen ziehen sich
rené stufe nachdem je nachdem was sie
einfach brauchen das machen die ganz
ganz von alleine
das heißt ihr könnt ihr gar nicht über
dünnen so zb aber mit coole geschichte
und ihr seht mal auch hinten mit der
natur die ihr habt ihr hinten steht zum
beispiel drauf los komm mal kurz her
jetzt habt ihr hier zum beispiel den
karabiner 300 oder 500 und derzeit an
fünf grad mahlgrad fünfmal kreis
sechsmal grad 7 steht ja alles drauf so
ich habe jetzt gar den dünger wagen
übrigens auch aus ulm ich möchte nochmal
erwähnen dass wir schwaben einfach die
coolsten sind jetzt neben mir einfach
diesen dingern
an dem tag ich jetzt hier rein
eigentlich unvorstellbar größerer total
natürlich jetzt habe ich ihn hier drin
und mit seinem jünger wagen wenn wir uns
eine große rasenfläche hatte ich immer
sagen am rasen fläche von 200
quadratmetern hat man so einen dinge
wagen und hier kann ich den auswurf
einstellen will ich nur seitlich lassen
hier in der mitte oder oder weit streuen
lassen hier in der mitte so und hier
haben auch sechs wie es auf der
verpackung draufsteht und jetzt nämlich
den dinger hier passt mal was jetzt
mache cds ist nicht genial
[Musik]
ihr seht dünne wagen ist es richtig los
und wenn ihr den rasen richtig gut mit
diesem naturdünger werden wir kein
unkraut haben wir werden keine sorgen
haben
und das tolle ist wenn er zum beispiel
haustiere ab 100 katzen hat wie auch
immer ihr habt kinder die im vom rasen
spielen das ist ein absolut aktion die
noch kein mineraldünger und du kannst
gar nicht über dünnen
[Musik]
und 120 kg hebt ungefähr 400
quadratmeter rasen
[Musik]
ja und oftmals wird den rasen verkauft
frühjahrs dünger sommer/herbst länger
braucht ihr alles natürlich nur ein
einzige die note erreicht das ganze jahr
und diesen dünger können ja auch für das
hochbeet benutzen für alle pflanzen und
das ist wirklich jetzt gesehen gerade
eben das ist der wahnsinn alles komplett
natur geht nicht ins grundwasser
die planten ziehen sich alles wie sie es
gerade benötigen und mehr brauchst du
nicht den perfekten rasen zu haben und
wenn du deinen rasen wirklich im jahr
dreimal dienst dann sage ich einst ihr
habt keine kein unkraut
ihr habt kein moos und ihr habt auch
nicht diesen tod spitze rich wenn ihr
nicht so große rasenflächen haben und
den vielleicht nicht braucht dann geht
es von gardena auch die mit der hand der
schneidkuhle für die hochbeete das
zeigen auch noch ganz kurz das hat zum
beispiel der ist auch ideal der
hochbeete oder einen pflanzenkübel oder
was weiß ich da drückt ihr einfach drauf
und macht das per hand ist auch kein
problem
oder wie gesagt kommen wir mit der hand
ist auch kein problem wenn ja auf
irgendwelchen kleinen stellen mal was
machen möchtet oder handschuhe wahnsinn
so jetzt habt ihr gesehen und hier ist
auch ein bisschen mehr dünger jetzt
welchen wagen als erstes drüber gefahren
bin und wenn jetzt ein mineral bin jetzt
mineraldünger hättet dann wird hier
wahrscheinlich brandflecken entstehen
wenn allem kommt das wasser ins ziel ist
es ein salz und hier gar kein problem
sagt perfekt jetzt seinen kohlen trägt
ihr werdet 100% irgendwo auf einer
rasenfläche einmal so eine coole drin
haben da hat sich einfach die erde
befestigt wenn ihr vielleicht dauernd
darauf gelaufen seid oder bei mir ist es
jetzt auch hier ihr seht hier eine
unebenheit hier ist es ein bisschen
weiter unten hier scheint der könig
darüber gelaufen die ganze zeit und
deswegen hat der boden müssen abgesagt
und der wichtigste nährstoff was der
boden braucht ist sauerstoff
das braucht der boden und hier hat sich
alles verdichtet und das sieht schön aus
und da gibt es einen ganz ganz coolen
trick den habe ich erfunden habe ich
nicht hab ich nicht erfunden doch habe
ich erfahren habe ich als ganz ganz cool
ist ein cooler trick macht es viel zu
hause nach oben wahrscheinlich sagen hey
kabel ist keine gabel weil es nicht so
spritzt das ist ein grab gabel isst
nimmt ihr die grab gabe jetzt macht ja
was ganz brutales und zwar geht mir der
grabgabel in den boden reif sagt so
jetzt bin ich im boden drin
und jetzt lupfig hier nur ein bisschen
hats gesehen wahnsinn so jetzt bringe
ich luft in den boden rein und da jetzt
die löcher drin sind dagegen fuß ein
bisschen drüber und sie ist nachher
nicht mehr
und das war jetzt hier nochmal überall
wo darüber ist er darunter ist so
[Musik]
so ist ein paar kleine tricks woher
wissen müssen um perfekten rasen zu
haben und wenn die das richtig macht wie
gesagt das ganze jahr über eine richtig
coole rasen noch einen anderen tipp was
ihr euch zu sagen möchte mitteilen
möchte ich auch ganz wichtig macht einen
fehler nicht ihr braucht keinen
golfrasen das heißt wir müssen im golf
rasen nicht auf 23 millimeter schneiden
macht sind wir so immer stellt den rasen
immer so ein dass er immer ein bisschen
höher ist weil eine höhere rasen hat
macht was eine höhere rasen ist wie die
belastbare der held vielmehr aus ist
richtig schön grün
es gibt so eine hausfrau will man sagt
immer man schneiden immer nur ein
drittel ab genau die ein drittel regel
merkt sie euch diesen saumäßig wichtig
wer anderer meinung ist da ist metzger
sowie ich vielleicht hat man all das
wieder schon gesehen wie ich nun da der
investor system eingebaut habe komplett
mit smartphones steuerung des n besser
das beweist ja immer nur nach bedarf und
das muss man auch winterfest machen und
ich war ja schlau genug und hab da
invest systeme eingebaut in westlings
ventile und wie machen meine gardena
entwässerungsanlage winterfest foley sie
was man auch das jetzt mache einfach
hier und hier habe ich den stecker von
der pumpe einfach herausgezogen
hingelegt jetzt gehe ich mal zu den
ventilen die wo die ganzen kreisläufe
steuern so das ist meine ganzen ventile
hier eins zwei drei vier mal drei sind
zwölf ventile richtig so
dann mache ich auch soll jetzt einfach
die ventile hier komplett sagte
kronprinz und hier schon in besserung
sven thiel und das macht jetzt auf das
leitungswasser kölns rein aber es war
schwer daher
und im frühjahr einfach alles umgekehrt
hier meist leicht auch einfach alles
wird auf manuell wieder umdrehen
doch auch auf gemacht jetzt vielleicht
das letzte stück wasser raus das war's
dann schon
der abgesehen ratz fatz winterfest
gemacht hat mich jetzt ungefähr fünf
minuten gekostet
das war's schon und im frühjahr mache
ich die pumpe auch wieder anlegt leben
wieder um und alles wieder automatisch
bewässert
[Musik]
und frieda soll es im winter natürlich
auch warm haben und zwar wohl ich find's
einfach raus macht frieda sauber und
stellt frieda dann einfach ins
gartenhäuschen schlaf gut frieda bis zum
frühjahr
so das ist jetzt unser teich winterfest
machen ist auch eine ganz ganz einfache
geschichte und sagt folgendes ich habe
keine fische drin wenn ich fische drin
hätte müsste ich was anderes machen aber
ich habe mich noch nicht getraut ist ja
viel schreien zu machen weil ich erst
mal wissen wollte wie so ein teich
funktioniert wie es dann ist wenn er
umkippt ja nicht umkippt dass sie
verstehen dass damit die fische nicht
sein sterben und will jetzt keine fische
drin habe dann muss ich weniger darauf
aufpassen wenn ich fische drin hätte
dann müsste ich irgendwelche reinstellen
damit sauerstoff wenn der teig zu
frieren damit die wache sauerstoff
bekommt muss ich in diesem fall nicht
haben vor allem haben wir hier nicht
diese ganz kalten winter ich habe darin
eine pumpe in der umwälzpumpe und diese
pumpe ist ungefähr bei zwei meter tiefe
oder 1 170 ungefähr
und das heißt es wird niemals frieden
die pumpe kann ich absolut drin lassen
das einzige was ich machen muss ist ins
gartenhäuschen gehen und da diese ganze
investors diese ganze filteranlage punkt
strom abbringen und einfach nur sauber
machen und somit ist meint auch komplett
interesse sodass ist es bei der oase
filteranlage und haben riesen vorteil
wir haben extra dieses gartenhäuschen
gebaut natürlich für geräte und für
alles was im garten brauche und weil es
jetzt im gartenhäuschen steht muss ich
das ding wie abbauen
ganz einfach was jetzt mache ist sagt so
jetzt habe ich alle stecker gezogen und
was ich jetzt mache ich nur das ganze
zeug einfach raus hier die ganze anlage
macht sie draußen sauber innen drin
alles sauber to die filter richtig schön
sauber machen und dann ich mein teich
auch winterfest und im frühjahr tue ich
alles nur anschließen das alles wir
laufen lasse die umwälzpumpen laufen du
bist ein paar bakterien rein für die
pflanzen und wenn dann ist ja alles in
ordnung ist dann mache ich fischereien
und zwar ganz normale viele von euch
haben wir geschrieben nach ja keine
goldfische weil die sich wahnsinnig
vermehren wie die pest und deswegen
überlege was ich mache mir ein paar
coole typ sagt für fische dann schreib
spiel in die kommentare
ich weiß goldfische wenn ich raus kaufen
so ist mir zu teuer habe ich keine lust
drauf vielleicht irgendwie vielleicht
die forelle vielleicht kann ja auch eine
forelle reim machen dann kann ich auch
grillen eine tolle geschichte
also schreibt mir was für fische wir
empfehlen aber dass man im frühjahr
was soll der mist noch zwei schritte
zurückgehen
helge schritte ja man sagen zwei celli
und beim morath schritte der garten ist
der winter fest der garten ist
winterfest und jetzt veranstaltung wer
ein winter fenster und jetzt schnell
noch ein höheres schonvermögen genau die
möbel stellen die ganzen polster holen
rein damit da auch nicht nass wird und
nicht genau was dem video nicht zu sehen
war ich hab noch ein
sicherheitshalber ließ gewendet hat noch
nichts darüber gemacht da seht ihr jetzt
genau jetzt kann ich so passt es perfekt
das heißt mein part ist eigentlich
erledigt und zu unterwegs hier noch zu
den resten genommen hatte meine arbeit
genau die hat schön vorbereitet
nur die harten kommen jetzt haben wir
jetzt haben wir den garten winterfest
gemacht ein pflanzen
es gibt auch noch einen garten
winterfest machen für tiere
ja und zwar schießen auf alles was sich
bewegt das war nur ein spaß hab's ganz
gut nach kinder zu wir schießen nicht
einstellen fall laufen beim auch nicht
hört zu macht sowas biete nicht wird es
ganz ganz kalt wird ganz wichtig möchte
noch zu erwähnen wenn es ganz kalt wird
und draußen jetzt schneit dann stellt
auf was auf jeder was raus willi igel
riegel und vögel genau ganz ganz wichtig
gewesen wäre ich da noch machen ich hab
das hast du da freut sich stellt was
raus wie vögel ganz wichtig das ok hat
richtig spaß gemacht mit euch das video
und sind ganz genau und ich warte auf
kommentare von euch ob das richtig war
was ich gemacht habe
und wenn es nicht richten immer falsch
machen was fall schaden genau ist kein
spaß ist mir das auch egal was gut war
gut ich war richtig los aber ich gehe es
rein
wir schauen keinen job
[Applaus]